we have something in common which is  that you're squeamish around the Sun I'm  very I like I like the Sun I just can't  be in it nor nor can die I abhor it it's  it's it's my greatest nemesis your  greatest nemesis is the Sun yeah I I  can't stand it and I think I have like  reverse seasonal depression disorder  because like the sunnier it is the more  of a bastard I am and like when it's  like overcast I'm chatting up strangers  and helping people with stuff this is I  relate to this completely because it's  been raining a lot lately in Los Angeles  and my assistant who's born and raised  here is in a foul mood I'm in heaven  yeah because I can go outside and I just  twirl every cell in my body it's like  that we're back in Ireland you know  [Applause]